thanks for calling the Magic Castle  Lambert yeah sure do 38.9  okay I warned you one drip in you're out  oh no kind of no oh by its mountain  inside to the Barbie thank you very much  he rested a lot these are the ones we're  not supposed to going but let's go  anyways meets the doctor said we have as  long we got again I wanna wait here you  don't well hey we've got a situation  here open up it's only second week of a  summer and there's already been a dead  fish in the pool we're trying to get it  back alive water bloom strong that  tourist I failed as a mother moaning  great new job  yeah if you're working who's looking  after mommy you're not my father  I don't want to be you bother me like  this  don't leak everybody knows what's up  really everybody  he's about to cry I cannot tell on the  girls whereabouts  [Music]  is my mommy I'm just talking with us  [Music]  I put yarns apart  [Music]  a web camera  [Music]  [Applause]  have a nice day love you too  you